they say i'm the french voice of the
steps
i know it sounds good and
some other voices than pork chops
i've dubbed many many
movies which i can't remember the
exact number always been very funny me
also i would be something about her
when i don't know i am but of which
i am actor director producer
filmmaker anton double you absolutely
have to look the actor in the eye
to give him the voice which is yours
which is no longer there  his
you are forced to embody yourselves
through him so very attentive and here
I want to leave with you being what
we are fixed the shift and the passion
that is that murphy created I sweat
sometimes to make a film that I
lose a kour 500  grams
because you have to get into it you have
to give it the voice
the difficulty of the meeting it's an
actor's job canton subtitle a thread
you have to look down to
read downstairs so this gesture makes you  it
loses in the image and the dubbing its sas
it allows you to simply
moviegoers and that the language where
people often prefer dubbing I
know that people when they watch it
and it's well done bailly its
l  empathy had with the character with
eddie murphy morgan freeman
it makes me happy to swim i did my
little stone well it's not bad it's
well done